who doesn't love their pets right
whether it's a dog a cat a goldfish or a
hamster any pet owner will tell you that
their furry friend is so much more than
just an animal that they adopted to many
pets become permanent additions to the
family while they might not look like a
human being or even have the ability to
speak the way we do a lot of owners view
their pets as people in their own right
of course a person can't be a pet at
least a human person can't right well
not unless you happen to be a part of
scp-1897
otherwise known as the human
domestication society if you've ever
been brave enough to travel alone to the
rural parts of southwestern states like
arizona new mexico texas oklahoma utah
or nevada then it's likely you would
have been an ideal victim for scp-1897
this designation doesn't refer to one
single creature or entity but rather a
group of similar beings witness
testimonies and photographs of
scp-1897 depict them as humanoid
creatures standing approximately five
meters in height these beings have
displayed a speed and strength far
beyond that of any human they are
capable of traveling roughly 200 meters
in only nine seconds and lifting weights
of up to 500 kilos with a single hand
these entities are not immortal and can
be harmed by conventional means but that
doesn't mean it's an easy task any
scp-1897 instance that is killed or
incapacitated immediately vanishes
resulting in them dropping anything that
they may have been carrying at the time
and surprisingly these are not mindless
monsters and actually appear to be
capable of communication furthermore
they do not seem to speak a unique or
distinct language but instead
communicate in standard american english
with accents and vernacular appropriate
to the regions they appear in however
they will actively refuse to reply to
any human that attempts to engage them
in conversation now these creatures
don't spend every waking hour of the day
roaming around the states of texas
oklahoma and all the others we listed if
they did it's likely a lot more
civilians would have spotted them by now
and would probably live their lives in
fear of these gigantic five meter tall
humanoids but instances of
scp-1897 will only manifest if certain
specific criteria are met and these are
as follows to encounter scp-1897
a person must be alone or part of a
group of no more than two if more than
one person is with them then no
manifestation will occur there is one
exception to the rule if a child under
the age of 12 is present secondly
neither the person nor anyone with them
can be carrying any kind of weapon that
means no knives no guns not even pepper
spray third and finally they must be at
least 25 meters from a major population
center and what happens when all these
conditions are met and one of these
creatures appears anyone witnessing
their arrival will notice the creatures
materializing appearing to emerge from
some form of unseen vehicle when they
manifest the
scp-1897 entities are almost always
carrying long poles with large nets at
the end as well as steel cages and are
often seen wearing dark green uniforms
in most cases they will attempt to
capture any nearby person in a way that
causes them the least possible harm
should an
scp-1897 creature successfully apprehend
a person and place them in a cage both
them and their captive will vanish in a
similar manner to the way the creature
appeared all attempts to track
scp-1897 or one of its abductive victims
have failed there is no way to know
where they are taken but as far as what
happens to them that we do have a little
more insight to sometimes although it is
a highly rare occurrence the captured
human victims may reappear around a
month after their capture while never in
the same location as where they
disappeared from they will always be
accompanied by an scp-1897
instance and will stay close by the
creature's side at this point the
abductee is barely human anymore they
are considered an instance of what is
known as scp-1897-1
signifies this sudden and drastic
transformation for one these victims are
always found to have been forcibly
castrated or sterilized essentially no
longer able to reproduce the way humans
naturally do for another these instances
of scp-1897-1
universally display a decreased level of
cognitive and mental function what we
mean is that their brains do not
function the way they should anymore
instead these abductees exhibit the same
level of intelligence and capability as
the average canis lupus familiaris
otherwise known as the common domestic
dog should someone attempt to rescue a
person that has become an instance of
scp-1897-1
or display hostility towards the
scp-1897 creature that accompanies them
they will be met with outward
animalistic aggression from the victim
it has been discovered by the scp
foundation that these behaviors can be
treated with amnestics unfortunately
though the process of an abducted person
becoming an scp-1897-1
instance seems to be the result of an
invasive medical procedure known as a
lobotomy this typically involves
removing or disabling certain parts of
the human brain meaning that what has
been done to these victims is permanent
and cannot be reversed so who is doing
all of this why are these creatures
collecting innocent human beings only to
reduce them to little more than animals
the answers lie in something currently
referred to as scp-1897-2
not another creature or entity not an
anomalous artifact or location with
strange properties but a website found
at the address www.hdsociety.gov
according to the information on this
site it belongs to a group calling
themselves the human domestication
society the website features pages such
as adoption training breeding programs
volunteering and more the fact that this
is the kind of website you might expect
to be about dogs or cats but instead
focuses on the domestication of humans
is certainly enough to turn the stomach
as we said at the start of the video
surely a human being can't be somebody's
pet right wrong at least as far as the
human domestication society goes their
website contains everything and anything
one of these
scp-1897 creatures could ever hope to
learn about owning a human as a pet has
your human been misbehaving need to
train them to use the toilet these pages
have all the information you need to
help your human become the most
well-trained human on your block boast
the training page of www.hdsociety.gov
the remainder of the page contains links
to various articles such as obedience
training which claims an owner of a
human can show them who's boss without
the need for physical violence also
featured are mentions of how to toilet
train or play fetch with a human how to
introduce a human to others due to them
naturally not getting along perhaps most
chilling of all is one article titled
understanding what your human wants that
warns human beings shouldn't talk and
another dealing with strays offers tips
for anyone wanting to learn to capture
their own pets themselves it doesn't
seem like too much of a leap to think
that the
scp-1897 creatures have followed a lot
of the advice from this particular
article arguably worst of all is an
image featured on the website of a tall
menacing
scp-1897 entity brandishing a picana
electrica this device for any unfamiliar
with the term is a form of high voltage
electrical cattleprod normally used for
the purposes of torture in the
photograph in question the creature is
wielding one of these while standing
sternly over a helpless captive human
male now an instance of
scp-1897-1 with tears in his eyes
further pages found on
www.hdsociety.gov recommend solutions to
certain human behaviors for example like
one might expect to find on other pet
care websites some of the human
domestication society's articles pertain
to dealing with aggression grooming
house training and even toilet training
then there's the adoption page which
states we offer a large variety of
humans for adoption every single day
while we cannot guarantee a human you
see listed on our website will be
available when you reach the shelter our
inventory is updated every half hour we
cannot answer any questions about
specific humans pictured on our website
over the phone or email it is still
unclear whether or not the
scp-1897 creatures that have been known
to appear in the southwestern united
states are sent out to gather humans and
mass to offer for adoption or whether
these creatures are individuals trying
to obtain human pets on their own of
course the worst conceivable answer is
both the site is horrifyingly
comprehensive with links to an actual
human ownership convention with panels
on breeding and preventing illegal human
poaching and skinning it's safe to say
if that you were ever unlucky enough to
read this website it would haunt you for
life naturally the scp foundation has
made several attempts to contact the
owners of this website they tried in
vain to communicate through the official
channels about
scp-1897-1 adoption has a way of
peacefully negotiating that the human
domestication society website be shut
down as well as its practices of
capturing lombotomizing breeding and
adopting humans however these
communication attempts were met with
silence that is until a message was
received by the foundation at site-06
addressed to a member of personnel that
does not exist no data pertaining to the
physical location of the sender could be
derived from the email but it was traced
to the same ip address as the human
domestication society's website the
email read as follows we will not listen
to your lies any longer it was you who
came after us first you who tore holes
in our world and tried to annihilate us
you who took our olive branch of peace
and fashioned it into a spear you who
nearly drove us to extinction and now
that we have the advantage you attempt
to patronize us with your crocodile
tears we will not be deceived again but
unlike you we are not monsters we have
much anger towards your kind but we are
willing to forgive but first you must be
willing to change slavery and genocide
are immoral and not even you deserve
such a fate it is our belief then that
this alternative is a fair compromise
between guaranteeing our safety and
allowing your kind to live this is our
mercy to you look at the humans who have
gone through our program see how much
happier they are your correspondence
tells us that you have seen them see how
much they love us why then do you
continue to be defiant someday you will
thank us please try to understand that
this is for your own good for now there
is little that the scp foundation can do
to prevent the human domestication
society from abducting human beings to
sell us pets to other
scp-1897 creatures civilian access to
the hd society.gov website has been
restricted so we recommend you stop
typing into the search bar of your
browser to go take a peek yes we mean
you
seriously stop that as for the entities
that have appeared in the rural areas of
the southwestern states all the
foundation can do is position its agents
nearby in the hopes that they can detain
and neutralize the
scp-1897s as they appear with lethal
force if necessary at present the only
procedure for any human pets that are
successfully recaptured is to have them
moved safely to containment until a way
of rehabilitating them is found so far
there hasn't been any luck on that front
now go check out
scp-1337 the hitchhiker and irresistible
pickup artist
scp-3512 the more you know for more
unforgettably disturbing anomalies
that'll chill you to the bone